este chile hecho de diversos pueblos y
naciones
instalados en una cornisa del continente
entre las cordilleras imponentes hizo
ceano mágico entre el desierto de vida y
los hielos antárticos
enriquecido y transformado por el
trabajo de su pueblo es este chile que
sólo en un puñado de años y ustedes lo
han vivido ha dividido a atravesar
terremotos catástrofes crisis
convulsiones y una pandemia mundial
y violaciones a los derechos humanos que
nunca más se repetirán en nuestro país
pero en el que siempre
siempre nos sacudimos del polvo nos
secamos las lágrimas ensayamos juntos
una sonrisa nos arremangamos y seguimos
chilenas y chilenos siempre seguimos
la emoción que sentía hoy día
al atravesar la plaza de la constitución
y entrar a este palacio
de la moneda es profunda y necesito
existencialmente necesito compartirla
con ustedes
son parte protagónica de este proceso el
pueblo de chile es protagónico en este
proceso no estaríamos aquí si las
movilizaciones de ustedes
y quiero que sepan que no llegamos aquí
sólo para llenar cargos y solazarnos
entre nosotros para generar distancias
inalcanzables llegamos aquí para
entregarnos en cuerpo y alma al
compromiso de hacer mejor la vida de
nuestra patria
quiero decirles compatriotas que he
visto sus caras
recorriendo nuestro país
las de las personas mayores
cuya pensión no les alcanza para vivir
porque algunos decidieron hacer de la
previsión un negocio
las de quienes enferman y sus familias
no tienen cómo costear los tratamientos
cuántos de ustedes nos han hablado no
hemos mirado los ojos
las de los estudiantes endeudados
las de los y los campesinos sin agua por
sequía y por saqueo
las de las mujeres que cuidan
a sus niños con tea que en cada lugar de
chile me las encuentro a sus familiares
postrados a sus bebés indefensos
las de las familias que siguen buscando
a sus detenidos desaparecidos
no dejaremos de buscar
las de las disidencias y diversidades de
género que han sido discriminadas y
excluidas por tanto tiempo
las de los artistas que no pueden vivir
su trabajo porque la cultura no es lo
suficientemente valorada en nuestro país
las de las dirigentes sociales que
luchan por el derecho a una vivienda
digna en las poblaciones de chile
las de los pueblos originarios
despojados de su tierra pero nunca nunca
de su historia
las de la clase media como taba las de
los niños y niñas del sename nunca más
nunca más
las caras de las zonas más aisladas de
nuestro país como el magallanes de donde
vengo
las de quienes viven en la pobreza
olvidada
con ustedes es nuestro compromiso
hoy
iniciado un periodo de grandes desafíos
de inmensa responsabilidad
pero no partimos de cero
no partimos de cero
chile
tiene una larga historia y hoy día este
día nos inserta en esa historia larga de
nuestra república
iniciar mi mandato como presidente
constitucional de la república de chile
es hacerme parte hacernos parte de una
historia que nos excede a todos pero que
al mismo tiempo le da forma le da
sentido y dirección a nuestra mirada
por aquí pasaron antes que nosotros
miles de personas que hicieron posible
la expansión de la educación pública el
reconocimiento progresivo de los
derechos de las mujeres y las
disidencias en el país y en la casa
la democratización del país el
reconocimiento de los derechos sociales
por aquí en este lugar desde donde hoy
les hablo paso balmaceda y su dignidad
chilena pedro aguirre cerda y sus
gobernar es educar citando a valentín
letelier
por acá paso también eduardo frei
montalvo y la promoción popular el
compañero salvador allende y la
nacionalización del cobre
patricio el wing y la recuperación de la
democracia
michelle bachelet abriendo caminos
inexplorados con la protección social
aquí se escuchan también los ecos de
quienes anónimamente se han levantado
contra la opresión
defendiendo los derechos humanos
exigiendo verdad justicia reparación y
garantía de los repeticiones por acá
resuena el clamor feminista y su lucha
por la igualdad
y algunos se acordarán también de las
1800 horas corriendo alrededor de la
moneda por la educación
pero estas paredes también han sido
testigos del horror
de un pasado de violencia y opresión que
no hemos olvidado y no olvidaremos
por donde hablamos hoy ayer entraban
cohetes y eso nunca más se puede volver
a repetir en nuestra historia
este palacio esta plaza esta ciudad y
este país tienen historia y esa historia
también nos debemos
hoy en esta jornada tan importante en el
difícil y difícil camino de los cambios
que la ciudadanía decidió echar a andar
en unidad
repito importante en unidad
vienen a mi mente y a mi corazón los
días en que junto a muchos de los aquí
presentes y seguramente que nos están
viendo en su casa también
marchamos juntos por un futuro digno
hacia dónde marcha vamos compatriotas
hacia dónde marcha vamos
no va a ser este gobierno el fin de esa
marcha vamos a seguir andando
y el camino sin duda va a ser largo y
difícil pero hoy los sueños de millones
de personas están acá
empujándonos dándonos sentido para
llevar a buen puerto los cambios que la
sociedad demanda
chilenas y chilenos mi sueño es que
cuando terminemos
nuestro mandato
y hablo en plural porque esto no es algo
individual esto no se trata de mí esto
se trata del mandato que el pueblo nos
diera a este proyecto colectivo cuando
terminemos este mandato podamos mirar a
nuestros hijos a nuestras hermanas a
nuestros padres a nuestras vecinas a
nuestros abuelos y sintamos que hay un
país que nos protege que nos acoge que
nos cuida que garantiza derechos y
retribuye con justicia el aporte y el
sacrificio que cada uno de ustedes de
los habitantes de nuestra patria hacen
para el desarrollo de nuestra sociedad
quisiera compatriotas en los ejemplos
uno siempre se queda corto pero quisiera
compatriotas que la gente de puchuncaví
y de coronel puedan mirar hacia el
futuro y saber que sus hijos no van a
crecer rodeados de contaminación algo
tan básico
que la gente los trabajadores de europa
no van a seguir viviendo en la pobreza
que las comunidades de a ligeras y
pescadores artesanales de la provincia
de cardenal caro podrán seguir
desarrollando sus actividades
tradicionales
que los niños y niñas de alto hospicio
allá arriba
sepan que ellos también van a poder
acceder a una vivienda digna que los
vecinos y vecinas de antofagasta de
maipú de hualpén sientan tranquilidad al
volver de sus trabajos y tengan tiempo
para vivir junto a sus familias por eso
impulsaremos como hemos comprometido las
40 horas
y en los jóvenes de juan fernández es el
lugar aislado insular van a poder tener
un colegio digno para estudiar
sabemos compatriotas que el cumplimiento
de nuestras metas no será fácil
que enfrentaremos crisis externas e
internas
que cometeremos errores
y que esos errores los deberemos de
enmendar con humildad
escuchando siempre a quienes piensan
distintos y apoyándonos en el pueblo de
chile
quiero decirles que vamos a vivir
tiempos desafiantes y tremendamente
complejos
[Música]
la pandemia
sigue su curso con un salvo de dolor y
pérdida de vidas que los va a acompañar
por mucho tiempo seguramente todos
ustedes conocen a alguien que ha partido
el producto de la pandemia
[Aplausos]
pensemos
pensemos por un segundo por un segundo
en que se han ido siquiera nos han
dejado
pensemos en el dolor
que tiene cada familia en su intimidad
por quien a partido y no volverá tenemos
que abrazarnos como sociedad volver a
querernos volver a sonreír
esto
más allá de discursos y más allá de lo
que esté escrito que importante que
diferente es cuando en un pueblo nos
queremos nos cuidamos entre nosotros no
desconfiamos el uno del otro sino que
nos apoyamos le preguntamos a nuestros
vecinos como está apoyamos al trabajador
del lado nos queremos salimos adelante
juntos y juntas eso es lo que tenemos
que construir compatriotas
sabemos también que la economía sigue
resentida y que el país necesita ponerse
de pie crecer y repartir de manera justa
los frutos de estos de este crecimiento
porque cuando no hay distribución de la
riqueza cuando la riqueza se concentra
sólo en unos pocos la paga es muy
difícil necesitamos redistribuir la
riqueza que producen los chilenos y
chilenas que producen quienes habitan
nuestra patria
sabemos que a todas estas dificultades
se suma además
un contexto internacional marcado
por la violencia
en muchos lugares del mundo y hoy
también por la guerra y en esto quiero
ser muy claro
chile en nuestro país promoverá siempre
el respeto de los derechos humanos en
todo lugar y sin importar el color del
gobierno que los vulnere
desde chile en nuestra américa latina
porque somos profundamente
latinoamericanos y basta de mirar con
distancia a nuestros países vecinos
somos profundamente latinoamericanos
y un saludo a nuestros pueblos hermanos
desde aquí desde este continente haremos
esfuerzos para que la voz del sur se
vuelva a escuchar
en un mundo cambiante
son tantos los desafíos la emergencia
climática los procesos migratorios la
globalización económica la crisis
energética la violencia permanente
contra las mujeres y disidencias tenemos
que trabajar juntos con nuestros pueblos
hermanos como lo conversábamos hoy día
con presidentes de otros países nunca
más mirarnos en menos nunca más mirarnos
con desconfianza trabajemos juntos en
américa latina' para salir adelante
practicaremos compatriotas la autonomía
política a nivel internacional sin
subordinar los nunca a ninguna potencia
y cautelando siempre en la coordinación
y cooperación entre los pueblos
[Aplausos]
quiero que sepan que como presidente de
chile
y nuestro gabinete
nuestros equipos
no le haremos el quite a los problemas
vamos a explicar vamos a hablar con
ustedes
para contarles el porqué de nuestras
decisiones para que sean parte también
de las soluciones y eso requiere también
cambiar de alguna forma la relación que
se tiene con las autoridades las
autoridades no pueden ser inalcanzables
queremos ministros en terreno en la
calle estando con el pueblo
queremos no hacer visitas a las regiones
que sean solamente de un par de horas
para inaugurar una obra hecha o escuchar
no estar escondido y para eso
es importante que también haya
reciprocidad y a qué me refiero con eso
que la relación con las autoridades no
sea una de consumidores que trabajemos
juntos que sean los ciudadanos y que
éste sea el gobierno del pueblo y
ustedes lo sientan como su gobierno de
todas y todos los chilenos y chilenas
y para eso nos vamos a necesitar todos
gobierno y oposición
instituciones y sociedad civil
movimientos sociales nuestro gobierno
cuya base política es apruebo dignidad y
también yo saludo a nuestros compañeros
que han trabajado tanto por esto y
también los partidos de convergencia
progresista quiero que sepan que no se
agota este gobierno no se agotan sus
adherentes
seré el presidente de todos los chilenos
y chilenas y escucharé siempre las
críticas constructivas y las propuestas
de quienes piensan distinto a nosotros
los que siempre siempre tendrán
garantizada la libertad y el derecho de
disentir
como he dicho más de una vez citando
palabras nacidas al calor de las
movilizaciones en un colegio tomado en
una población lejos en una región
perdida
porque de las movilizaciones venimos hoy
día estamos acá pero no nos olvidamos de
dónde venimos
vamos lento porque vamos lejos vamos
lento porque vamos lejos y no vamos
solos sino que con todos ustedes hombres
mujeres niños y niñas que nos acompañan
hoy en esta plaza a través de sus
pantallas en sus casas quizás en el
celular en la micro quizás de donde sea
que nos estén viendo en el extranjero
quienes también nos están siguiendo y
añoran a su chile querido
porque es central como he repetido
varias veces en este discurso que
ustedes se hagan parte de este proceso
porque no podemos hacerlo solos
desde este lugar quiero hacerles a todas
ya todos
un llamado que nos acompañemos en esta
tarea
caminemos juntos la ruta de la esperanza
y construyamos todos el cambio hacia un
país que sea digno y justo dignidad que
palabra tan linda
[Música]
no construiremos paso a paso
con la sabiduría de quien sabe que los
cambios que duran son los que tienen
sustento en el conocimiento
acumulado y que son respaldados por
grandes mayorías
pondremos especial atención como el
señalado a los efectos que la pandemia
ha tenido sobre el sistema de salud
sobre los trabajadores y trabajadoras
que nos han protegido y cuidado sobre
las listas de esperas que tanta angustia
genera en la familia vamos a continuar
también la exitosa estrategia de
vacunación del pasado gobierno colocando
siempre la salud de las personas como
prioridad primera y también
implementaremos una estrategia
específica para atender las
consecuencias de la salud mental porque
la salud mental también importa chilenos
y chilenos
nos vamos a preocupar
específicamente por la educación
donde había una brecha gigante
producto de la obligación de cerrar las
escuelas tenemos que volver a abrir las
escuelas para que nuestros niños y niñas
vuelvan a encontrarse generando por
cierto todas las condiciones de
seguridad para que ello sea posible
vamos a implementar
con mucha energía
la consolidación de nuestra economía
recuperar nuestra economía sin
reproducir sus desigualdades
estructurales un crecimiento que sea
sustentable nunca más zonas de
sacrificio el estado también es
responsable
[Aplausos]
queremos que las pequeñas y medianas
empresas que generan valor vuelvan a
crecer
queremos terminar con los abusos que tan
injustamente que tan justamente han
indignado a nuestro pueblo y queremos
volver a generar en conjunto
recuperando también dándoles seguimiento
a las buenas ideas de antes
empleo digno
reconocemos también que millones de
chilenos y chilenas primero hoy día con
temor
no podemos mirar para el lado antes y
vamos a enfrentar el problema de la
delincuencia
enfrentando la desigualdad social que su
origen y también con una reforma a las
policías que asegure presencia en los
lugares donde más se necesita
y aumente la efectividad de la
investigación y que se concentre en las
organizaciones criminales y de narcos
que destruyen nuestros barrios le doy un
mensaje a quienes han hecho de la
delincuencia algo común y que creen que
pueden vivir en la impunidad
no quiero frases grandilocuentes quiero
decirles que los vamos a enfrentar con
la comunidad con la comunidad y quiero
decir también que necesitamos reparar
las heridas que quedaron del estallido
social
y por eso
el día de ayer
y por eso el día de ayer hemos
retirado
hemos retirado las querellas por ley de
seguridad del interior del estado
porque tenemos la convicción de que como
chilenos y chilenas tenemos que volver a
encontrarnos y vamos a trabajar vamos a
trabajar intensamente en aquello lo
hemos conversado con los familiares de
los presos saben que estamos en ello
sabemos también compatriotas que
enfrentaremos grandes desafíos en el
norte y en el sur en el norte por la
crisis migratoria donde vamos a retomar
el control de nuestras fronteras y
trabajaremos junto a nuestros países
hermanos para abordar de manera
colectiva las dificultades que conlleva
el éxodo de miles de seres humanos no
nos olvidemos nunca que son seres
humanos por favor
quiero decirle a la gente de colchones a
la gente de iquique antofagasta de san
pedro' que no van a estar solos
a la gente de arica por cierto
quiero también
decir de que en el sur
tenemos un problema
el conflicto que no es como se usa se
hablaba de la pacificación de la
araucanía que terminó más burdo e
injusto
después de algunos decían el conflicto
mapuche no señores no es el conflicto
mapuche es el conflicto entre el estado
chileno y un pueblo que tiene derecho a
existir
[Música]
y allí
la solución no es ni será la violencia
trabajaremos incansablemente
por reconstruir las confianzas después
de tantas décadas después de tantas
décadas de abuso y de despojo
el reconocimiento a existir de un pueblo
con todo lo que eso implica será nuestro
objetivo y el camino será el diálogo la
paz el derecho y la empatía con todas
las víctimas y con todas las víctimas
cultivemos cultivemos la reciprocidad no
nos veamos como enemigos tenemos que
volver a encontrar
en este primer año de gobierno
también nos hemos impuesto como tarea
acompañar de manera entusiasta nuestro
proceso constituyente por el que tanto
hemos luchado
vamos a apoyar decididamente
decididamente el trabajo de la
convención
necesitamos una constitución que nos una
que sintamos como propia una
constitución que a diferencia de la que
fue impuesta a sangre fuego y fraude por
la dictadura nazca en democracia
de manera paritaria
con participación de los pueblos
indígenas
una constitución que sea para el
presente y para el futuro
una constitución que sea para todos y no
para unos pocos los invito a que nos
escuchemos de buena fe
sin caricaturas
sin caricaturas tomemos no lo en serio
de todos los bandos
no lo digo a nosotros mismos también
escuchemos de buena fe sin caricaturas
para que el plebiscito de salida sea un
punto de encuentro y no división y
podamos aquí junto al pueblo firmar por
primera vez la historia de chile una
constitución democrática paritaria con
participación de todos y todos nuestros
pueblos
chilenos y chilenas el mundo nos está
mirando
[Aplausos]
quiero decirles chilenos y chilenas que
el pueblo no está mirando
el mundo nos está mirando y estoy seguro
de que también ven con complicidad lo
que está pasando en chile
tenemos una oportunidad de
ir aportando humildemente a la
construcción de una sociedad más justa y
estoy seguro que vamos a estar a la
altura de este proceso democrático que
fue decidido por una inmensa mayoría
ciudadana repliquemos ese resultado
queridos habitantes de nuestra tierra
a su voz
con humildad con conciencia de las
dificultades del mandato que ustedes me
han confiado
lo hago también con la convicción de que
sólo en la construcción colectiva de una
sociedad más digna podremos fundar una
vida mejor para todos y todas en chile
no sobra nadie la democracia la
construimos juntos y la vida que soñamos
solo puede nacer de la convivencia el
diálogo la democracia la colaboración y
no la exclusión
se que en cuatro años más el pueblo de
chilenos juzgará por nuestras obras y no
por nuestras palabras y que como decía
un viejo poeta del adjetivo cuando no da
vida mata hoy era necesario hablar
mañana todos juntos a trabajar
pronosticar hace casi 50 años salvador
allende estamos de nuevo
compatriotas abriendo las grandes
alamedas por donde pase el hombre libre
el hombre y la mujer libre
[Aplausos]
una sociedad mejor
pero chile
[Aplausos]